they're very concrete habits that you
can use that I have used once you get
your mind in the right place once you
believe that it can happen this is what
I did I worked out why because it helped
me gain control of my mind one it was
micro credibility with myself every day
I said I was going to do something I did
it two when you're suffering and you're
willing to fight through it you tell
yourself a story that you're willing to
pay the price to become what you want to
become and also when you watch your body
transform you get the loudest signal
from your subconscious that you can
change that you can change anything you
want that you can change your bicep your
tricep your quad whatever it is you want
something that you literally could not
do the day before you can do today and
your mind sees that that's true your
mind sees that something you couldn't
pick up yesterday you can pick up today
and it begins to ask itself well if
that's possible then what else is
possible now for me finding my Center
was also a very important thing so I
work out first the next thing I do
without fail is Tate I do a just breathe
meditation where I'm simply trying to
calm my mind then I do what I call
thinkitating during meditating I get
into an alpha wave state brain pattern
which enhances creativity and unique
connections I'm not worried about
whether I'll ever think a unique thought
I am simply interested in the unique
connections that I will make that no one
else before me or after me will ever
make and that to me is what makes each
of us a beautiful snowflake I read I
read obsessively because I believe in
one simple math equation ideas in equal
ideas out and then I keep a list of the
most important things I'm trying to
accomplish if you're trying to become
something you need to know what that
something is you are what you
consistently do the difference between
where you are right now and where you
want to be is what are you consistently
doing every single day your habits will
determine your ultimate success one of
the reasons why I've had so much success
on YouTube is because I just keep making
videos it's a habit it's burdened to my
calendar
every week I am making video videos I
film I'm here making this content for
you guys now I'm making more videos more
videos more videos more videos it's
consistently been a part of my routine
for over a decade if you do something
every single week or more frequent for a
decade you're gonna get some serious
results you'd have to be just absolutely
terrible to not get any results if you
are doing something every single week or
more frequently for a decade most people
don't want to put in the work and I get
it and that can be frustrating it can be
slow we want the instant results
and it's hard to shift the identity your
identity at the beginning
because your habits of not doing
something or your current habits that
you are doing are stronger than the new
habit that you're trying to build
so for me not to make a video would be
so foreign so weird I've made videos
through all sorts of Crisis and and
tragedies and injuries the only time
when I didn't make videos was when my
dog died when my family dog died was on
video day and I just couldn't bring
myself to making the videos this was the
only week where I like zero I can't do
it
we have to do something else but I've
made videos through vacations I've made
videos through breaking my neck I've
made videos through I everything every
tragedy that's happened every negative
every every stress every frustration
I've found a way to make videos it's so
a part of me now not because I'm
superhuman or extra special just because
I put the reputation in
now a new habit that I'm trying to build
is swimming
the pool just opened back up in my place
and I've gotten swimming every day for
the past two weeks week and a half I'm
going swimming and it's so it's so fun
it's so freeing I go for my swim I
started I could only do 20 lengths of
the pool now I'm up to 40 and I'm
getting better at it and I feel I just
feel so good you swim you have a shower
and they're like oh my body feels
amazing right now but it's still a new
habit
right I'm still trying to develop it if
I were to go
and fly to a speaking gig and then come
back I would have to force myself to get
back into oh right swimming swimming
that's what I'm supposed to do in the
morning I gotta go swimming right right
I'd have to set up reminders have to put
it in my calendar
but making videos is so ingrained
because it's lasted so long as I've done
it feels super weird if I if I left
YouTube or sold my Channel or whatever
like oh what do I do now I don't even
know what to do anymore because making
videos has become part of my identity
you too can change your identity you too
can start to develop the habits that
will help take you to accomplishing your
goals I want to give three quick tips
that I think will help step number one
is to get really clear on what the Habit
is that you want to develop don't pick
20 different habits that you would want
to do all at once this is where we we
struggle because we take on way too much
like okay that's it I'm done I'm rolling
up my sleeves it's time to change my
life I've had it I've had enough I'm
gonna change everything I'm gonna work
out and I'm gonna I'm gonna eat well and
I'm gonna make content I'm gonna grow my
business I'm gonna find a girlfriend I'm
gonna like whatever the thing is you
come with 20 different habits that
you're gonna do
and guess what you do it tomorrow maybe
and then and then it becomes too
overwhelming too much too much change
all at once
your life just takes over and you end up
back down in the hole where you started
does that happen if you try to take on
too much at once what is the single most
important habit that you need to start
to build that if you look back in a year
you could say I'm so happy that I built
this one habit because it's helping you
accomplish your goals what is the most
important habit it could be waking up at
a certain time it could be taking care
of your your mind it could be taking
care of your body it could be putting in
a certain amount of work on your
business it could be right in your book
it could be making 100 videos like what
is the one habit
that you want to start to build that if
that one thing happened
your entire life starts to change
it's the Cornerstone habit that you
start doing that because they guarantee
you listen if you start waking up at a
certain time or you start working out
you pick any of them you start doing one
of those things that you're proud of
yourself for doing it other things start
to change in your life around you
because when you feel really proud of
yourself when you feel good about
yourself
other things start to improve too
because if you were say your goal is to
make 100 videos next year okay so every
three days you're making a video
and that's impossible you've never done
that and that sounds crazy and it's way
too big and then you start to do it
you start to actually build the momentum
you start to actually make the content
he said like okay well what else what
else can I do
you know what I want to I want to I want
to start working on health
it's just gonna happen naturally
you want to find a relationship people
will gravitate towards you
because now all of a sudden you're a lot
more confident a lot more proud that's
magnetic energy that people want to be
around
so you pick the one habit that you want
to stay consistent on
and then you start doing that work not
being stressed out about having too many
habits all at once and the whole thing
fails okay set number two you have to
schedule it
you have to put it in your calendar
schedule it it will not just happen
these videos are happening for me right
now
it's in my schedule
I booked time for
I have swimming in my schedule that's
that's even more important in my
calendar so today at five o'clock I'm
gonna go swimming it's in my calendar I
booked it
because otherwise other stuff could come
in maybe I get on a roll I'm making
videos or maybe somebody messages me and
I have to deal with it something else
will always come up something else will
always come up right stuff always comes
up
and we let that be an excuse for you not
to take action
you block it off you put it in your
calendar show yourself when right which
day of the week are you actually going
to be doing this thing or which time of
day are you actually going to be doing
this thing
and start to teach yourself that this
gets done that when you put less things
in your calendar right put less things
in your calendar and make sure that they
get done because you can put stuff in
you how many times you put stuff in your
calendar or anything get done right does
that happen to you
don't worry about that less things in
your calendar but when you put it in it
gets done again this is building the
identity it's you starting to trust
yourself that when you say something's
gonna happen that it happens and that
just happens one off but it happens
consistently
so you if you've got holidays coming up
or vacation coming up and your goal is
still to do videos or swimming or write
write a page for your book or whatever
it is that is part of your goals
plan your calendar
show yourself what time okay you know
you're traveling tomorrow
[Music]
okay are you gonna do it before you
travel you're gonna do it while you're
on the plane you're gonna do it when you
land in the city and what's realistic
are you going to be doing a 16-hour
flight with two stopovers and then be
exhausted when you land and that's when
you're going to do your workout
right like maybe work out in the morning
like just think about your day that's
coming ahead of you and schedule that
thing in because again when you can stay
consistent on it that's when everything
starts to change
and at number three is get a community
doing something difficult and doing
something brand new is really really
really hard to do by yourself it's not
impossible it's not that you can't do it
but we are we are Community people like
humans are even even me who's
introverted and shy and I don't need a
lot of friends
it's always more fun doing something
with somebody knowing that tonight at
five Nina's going swimming with me
I'm more likely to show up because
Nina's there too
it's going to be a lot more fun because
Nina's there too get somebody to be an
accountability partner for you join a
Discord group or Facebook group that are
talking about these things so that you
don't feel like you're the only person
going through this because when you have
a down day when you have a bad moment
when you're tired when you had a rough
sleep when you got a terrible news
it's easy to fall right back down to the
habits that you've been consistently
working on the negative have is even
building up over your lifetime instead
of defaulting back to the positive ones
that you want to start to build
the difference between where you are
right now and where you want to be are
the habits you consistently do you are
what you consistently do
you eat one chocolate bar it's fine as
long as you're consistently eating
really well but if you eat really well
only one day and you're eating chocolate
bars every day then guess what's going
to happen to your health
you are what you consistently do and you
can change it
you can change it where you are right
now does not have to be where you are in
one year if you put the habits in place
if you consistently schedule them in
and you get a community to help you so
you're not doing this alone
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a
day for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
you can't make a racehorse out of a pig
but you can make a really fast Pig
your life can be the answer to what does
a fast pig look like that is certainly
what my life is all the success that
I've had in my life is not because I was
gifted at any one thing when I left for
college my mother quietly assumed I was
going to fail my best friend assumed I
was going to marshmallow my way through
life when I asked my father-in-law for
his Blessing to marry his daughter he
said no
and yet I went on to be successful to
earn my father-in-law's respect
um
not because they misidentified me
because they didn't they were right
but because I developed Drive I got the
only belief that mattered and I finally
realized that
humans are meant to grow and get better
at something and I just have to apply
myself and the same is true for you
decide what you want to get good at and
go after it with everything you've got
and that my friends is how you overcome
negativity as Henry Rollins said I don't
have talent so I just get up earlier
the thing that people think about
becoming great about doing the
extraordinary is that it's just meant
for some people and not meant for others
and they spend their time making other
people extraordinary
as a way to let themselves off the hook
because if somebody is just gifted if
they were blessed by God if they were
Touched by an Angel and they just have
something that you don't and something
that you never will have then it's fine
for them to be great and you to be
ordinary but the reality is it's not how
it works but somehow the cultural
narrative has become one where we
celebrate natural talent that if
somebody is graced by God that if they
have something Divine about them that
they're somehow better that it's more
beautiful than the scrappy person who's
had to work for everything they've ever
had the guy who simply acknowledges like
Henry Rollins that he doesn't have more
Talent than the next person he's simply
willing to outwork them he's willing to
set the alarm to get up to do whatever
it takes to find his path to create that
skill to outwork talent to show that by
putting in that energy and that effort
there's a magnification effect that is
far greater than anything that can be
given to you bestowed upon you you have
to grab it you have to take it you have
to have a level of intensity in your
life to be able to leverage it and
create something amazing
as Warren Buffett said intensity is the
if you want to be to be great
cultivate that intensity you've got to
understand it's not about what you were
born with it's not about what you were
given where you started or even where
you're going it is entirely about what
you plant at the center of your soul how
hard you're willing to go after
something how much Focus you're willing
to put in your life and how often you
come back to that level of intensity for
who you want to be
because if you want to be excellent
you will have to pay a price
and that price is eternal vigilance
vigilance over how you spend your time
Vigilant over the demands you make of
yourself vigilance over what you allow
yourself to think and believe and when
you get to the point that you only allow
yourself to think and believe things and
move you towards your goals that every
day the actions you take are things that
are designed to get you there and that
you have the intensity to follow that
through to shape yourself to create a
new version of you capable of doing
something extraordinary then your life
is going to be what you want
foreign
it's never going to be anything if you
just make other people extraordinary and
say I could never do that
the reality is you could and you're just
not
so the thing that you have to face right
now is that it is within your grasp
you just have to go after it and let me
tell you passion is not something you
were born with drives me nuts everybody
thinks they're going to turn inside like
an archaeologist and find that thing
their deepest passion the thing they
always love hiding inside
is as soon as you say it I hope it
sounds ridiculous that you would love
something that much and yet somehow be
blind to it
it doesn't work like that
it's like real love you've got to go on
a date first you see somebody you're
interested in you talk to them it Sparks
something you spend time you engage
and through that process of engaging
with it
maybe if you're lucky it turns into a
fascination
but if you really want a passion
you've got to go through the process of
gaining mastery
and Mastery is the part of the
relationship and business or in Romance
where everybody falls apart because it's
where the work starts it's where you
have to do things long after it stop
being fun now the process of taking
myself from scrounging my couch cushions
to find enough change to put gas in my
car
to building a billion dollar business
was all about building a set of beliefs
now I believe
that the Matrix has us all
I don't actually think we live in a
simulation but I think the movie The
Matrix is the perfect metaphor for The
Human Experience we have all pulled a
Web of Lies over our own eyes and the
Web of Lies is what you tell yourself
about what's possible for you and for
the world
and once you get that Web of Lies over
your eyes you simply see it as reality
and you don't understand that each one
of those fundamental beliefs is
alterable but you could choose to
believe something else in fact you don't
even realize that they are beliefs
Einstein has a quote
it's one of the most important quotes in
my life
the most important question
any man must decide for himself
is whether or not he lives in a friendly
or hostile universe
now what I love about that quote is
what's hiding in it is that it's a
decision
you get to choose whether you're living
in a friendly or hostile universe
there's no objective reality
it just is what it is you're gonna get
what you see you're gonna get what you
focus on
and you see what you focus on so many
people are obsessed with becoming
perfect that they never take action and
they never learn to enjoy this moment
that may be one of the greatest
tragedies any of us can face that right
now whatever we are however we are
however good we are whatever we've
accomplished
that we fail to enjoy this moment
because we have a judgment about who we
are deep down because we haven't acted
in a way that's perfect and I get it we
have this drive that's innaten us we
want to be great it's one of the five
primary human drivers to pursue Mastery
to want to master something and truly be
extraordinary
I understand the drive
don't let it corrode you don't ever do
something that eats you alive from the
inside you've got to have a vision of
yourself that allows you to morph and
change and learn from your mistakes but
if you value Perfection over learning
then you're never going to become the
person that you'd be capable of becoming
and as Anna quindlin said the thing that
is really hard and really amazing
is giving up on being perfect
and beginning the work of becoming
yourself let me tell you something that
is true beyond measure
the struggle is guaranteed
the success is not
the struggle is a guarantee
so you better love what you do on a
day-to-day basis
read Eckhart tolles The Power of Now the
only moment that's real is right now
follows you so every time you're doing
something if you're standing and staring
and waiting for someone to finish going
to the restroom or whatever you're
standing in line at Disneyland that is
your life that is the sum total of what
you are about in that moment and life is
simply a string of those moments and so
you've got to start asking yourself am I
using those moments wisely everything
around you is incredible if you're
willing to look at it that way
everything around you can be taken for
granted if that's your perspective
but it really is about the frame that
you choose to put around things I mean
simply being alive is already insane the
odds are so stacked against you not only
just being a human but being a human at
this moment in time this moment in time
where breakthroughs and Technology are
happening at at an unprecedented rate
where breakthroughs in medical science
are happening at an unprecedented rate
where our ability to connect with people
to empathize with people all the way
around the globe all of the changes that
have happened in technology and Telecom
and connectivity Health everything
we're living in the most miraculous time
ever
but you have to look at it that way
and as Joseph Campbell said life is a
wonderful wonderful Opera
except that it hurts so the question is
do you see it as the beautiful opera or
do you just pay attention to the pain
and at the end of the day you're gonna
get what you focus on they're both true
this is both the most amazing time
that's ever happened ever in recorded
history
and yet real things that are terrifying
or also happening
but where you put your energy where you
put your attention where you put your
focus is going to determine what you see
and that is the most fascinating and the
most important thing you have to
understand about the way that your mind
works you get what you focus on if you
focus on the things that are bad they
will become real they will become
exaggerated they will begin to
monopolize your thoughts you'll see them
everywhere it's called the reticular
activating system your mind is literally
designed
to pay attention to the things that you
notice
once you notice a certain car you see it
everywhere once you notice a certain dog
you see it everywhere once you hear a
certain name for the first time suddenly
realize that that name has been all
around you this entire time but now that
you're focusing on it now that you're
looking for it it is everywhere
so whatever you look for it's going to
be everywhere if you look for the
negative it'll be there but if you look
for the positive it will overwhelm you
and if you guys haven't read the book
anti-fragile by Naseem taleb do
in that book he lays out the difference
between something that is resilient
and something that is truly anti-fragile
I'm gonna say somebody that's
Unstoppable is truly anti-fragile and
what anti-fragile is the more you attack
it the stronger it gets so something
that is resilient or tough it is still
defined by its Breaking Point the more
you go after it eventually it will break
something that's anti-fragile grows with
that
and I believe each and every one of us
can build a mindset that is truly
anti-fragile there is only one thing
that I have found that is actually
anti-fragile and it looks like this
I was there with my partners they
routinely made me feel stupid all the
time they were older than me they were
more than 10 years ahead of me on their
entrepreneurial Journey
and so I was just wrong all the time now
up to that point in my life I actually
called myself the king of remedial jobs
up until then I'd only gone for jobs
where I knew I'd be smarter than the
person interviewing me I knew that at
some point during the interview they
were going to ask that magical question
which made me feel so good about myself
which was why are you here
why are you interviewing for this job
and I lived for that because it made me
feel smart
so here I am now not in that world
anymore I'm with guys who are way ahead
of me they're way smarter than me
and I feel dumb all the time and one day
I find myself arguing for this path in
our business because it was my idea
and I knew it was wrong that was a
hilarious thing I knew it was wrong and
yet I was arguing for it like really
passionately and then all of a sudden it
actually worked
and they agreed to do it and I thought
oh
now what
I've been telling my wife that I'm gonna
make her rich and here I am arguing for
something that just makes me feel good
about myself
and I had this moment of crisis
and I asked myself
no judgment
what do you really want
because if what you really want is to
feel good about yourself to feel smart
to be right to be worthy if those are
the things that you want then get out of
this company because you're wrong often
you're making mistakes all the time and
your partners are so far ahead of you
that they make you feel stupid
so this is like that doesn't make any
sense so if you want to just go feel
good go back to being the king of
remedial jobs be in places where you're
always feeling smart where you're
usually right and live that life
but if on the other hand what you really
want is to actually reach your goals
then you're gonna have to stop worrying
about feeling good about yourself
and both of those felt flawed
everybody needs to feel good about
themselves
that that's just the reality of being a
human you've got to find a way to feel
good about yourself
but I really believe everything you do
in life should be in service of your
goals
and the moment that you're acting out of
alignment with your goals you either
have a problem with your goal or with
your behavior one of them is going to
have to change
and so I realized in that moment that I
needed to change what I was building my
self-esteem around because I was
building it around being right and I was
wrong so much I was building it around
being smart and I just wasn't that smart
I was building it around being good and
worthy and the fact is those were just
judgments on myself
and so I decided right then and there
it's the one thing in my life that
borders on truly being an epiphany
and I realized I need to change what I
build my self-esteem around and it needs
to be something
that I didn't have the word anti-fragile
at the time but something that the more
somebody goes after it the better off
I'm going to be the more it's going to
push me towards my goals and that thing
is and if somebody has a better answer I
will take it but the only
way to build your ego that is truly
anti-fragile that I have found is to be
the learner
to be willing to admit when you're wrong
to look at your goal and work backwards
and say is what I'm doing actually
moving me towards my goal or not not
does it make me feel good about myself
not am I right not am I smart is it
moving me towards my goal and if it is
then you do it and if it doesn't then
you don't
and my life became that cut and dry and
you can literally draw a line in the
sand a demarcation point of my life
before that and my life after that as
Kurt Vonnegut one of the greatest
authors in modern times said when I
write I feel like an armless legless man
with a crayon in his mouth
but he still did it
and that's the kind of thing that you're
going to hear from the greats you're not
going to hear that it was easy you're
not going to hear that they felt Suave
and cool even the greatest of all time
have that awkwardness that clumsiness
they're never quite as good as they want
to be but what I want you to understand
is even though Kurt Vonnegut said those
words
he wrote tons of books that changed
people's lives that changed the
landscape of literature because despite
the fact that he felt awkward and clumsy
he kept doing it and doing it and
forcing himself to move forward to take
one step after another even when the
process
was not exactly rewarding he believed in
something he knew that what he was
trying to do would ultimately get better
he knew that if he wanted to accomplish
something great that he had to push
through the awkwardness and that is the
very trick to getting great
you just have to do it you have to go
you have to take that first step you
have to push you have to drive you have
to strive every time to get a little bit
better you have to strive not to fall
prey to your own doubts and insecurities
and as Joe Namath said
if you aren't going all the way why go
at all whatever your skill set is now
whatever your vision of yourself is now
you can change it you can become
anything you want to be
but life is going to ask you one simple
question what price are you willing to
pay to get there
and that's it that's the hard truth if
you're willing to pay the price then you
can become whatever you want you can
become truly capable of the
extraordinary
but you've got to go through the process
of building that skill set you've got to
be willing to stare nakedly at your
inadequacies
to understand that you aren't yet the
person that you want to be or need to be
to execute against your goals but that
you can become that person and then
start walking down that path and day by
day Brick by Brick build the skill set
that you want as harun Yaya noted
I always wonder why birds stay in the
same place when they can fly anywhere on
Earth
and then I ask myself the same question
as Mark Twain put it the secret of
getting ahead is getting started
and that's where people get stuck you're
literally like the bird you could fly
anywhere you want you can go anywhere
you want to go and look I know you've
got a Litany of excuses and all of them
are valid you've got a job you can't
just leave or you don't have a job and
you don't have them
holding you back and making you a less
version of yourself so I ask you
why doesn't the bird fly wherever it
wants to go
because that's all it's known
because that's what's safe because
that's what's comfortable or because
it's a dumb animal
what do you want to be if this isn't the
life you want to live
do something about it humans lead with
belief that may be the single most
important thing to understand humans
lead with belief meaning you don't do
something and then believe you can do it
you won't even take the first step if
you don't believe that your actions will
be rewarded with results that's why so
many people are paralyzed because
they think that they're not worthy they
think they're or they know they're
uneducated they know that they're not
the person that they need to be in order
to accomplish
and the reality is you're probably not
the fact is your skill set has already
taken you as far as it's going to take
you so if you are unsatisfied with where
you are today I have some horrifying
news for you I'll Chase it with some
good news but first let's start with the
bad
the bad news is
your life is an exact reflection of the
choices you've made that's it it's not
circumstance it comes down to skill set
and choices you've chosen to build a
certain skill set you've chosen to do
certain things take certain risks play
certain things safely whatever the case
may be those were all choices now your
life is a reflection of that what I want
you to understand though the belief the
only belief that you need to have
that thing that is going to allow you to
take that first step is not to believe
that you're capable
of what you're trying to build because
we all know you're not
I knew that I wasn't when we started
Quest I knew I wasn't the person that I
needed to be I understood that it just
didn't paralyze me
because I believed one thing
and if you take nothing else from what I
say today burn the following statement
into your soul
humans are the ultimate adaptation
machine
that's it
Charles Darwin is often misquoted as
saying
that it's the strongest of the species
that survive
he'd never said that what he actually
said was it's not the strongest of the
species that survived nor the most
intelligent but rather the most adaptive
to change
we're the apex predator for a reason
because unlike any other animal we have
the ability to go in any direction any
direction we want we're the only species
that you can find anywhere at one point
James Cameron was actually at the bottom
of the Marianas Trench
we can Thrive anywhere from Inuits
living in the tundra
to peoples that have survived in the
desert
because humans adapt that is the
fundamental nature of what we are so
then these two successful entrepreneurs
walk into my class and up to that point
I'd promised myself two things so I grew
up chubby in a morbidly obese family and
with no money and I said one day I'm
going to be rich and one day I'm going
to have six-pack abs and that was my
promise and these guys walked in and
they were rich and they had six-pack abs
and they said look we're starting a
technology company why don't you come be
a copywriter and I was like absolutely
and it's one of those where people like
what are you doing like you're leaving
the secure job for me I was like they're
like unicorns to me yeah they are
literally the thing I'm looking for they
are rich and they have six pack abs
they're gonna let me into their company
yeah and so their whole pitch was look
man this is a startup you can have any
job in this company you want you just
have to become the right person for the
job so it was a tech company it was in
this beautiful office overlooking the
Pacific Ocean every single person in
that company had a floor to ceiling
window overlooking the Pacific Ocean
except me and they put me in the server
room which had no windows and a bunch of
computers all worrying and making noise
and I remember one of the guys was like
who's the kid in the server room and so
that's how I became known I was the kid
in the server room I know anything about
business I would bring my wife she's to
visit me in the office and I'm like look
how beautiful the office is and this is
where I'm at you know and like literally
like those makeshift deaths that are
like really like a table that you would
use on a picnic you've got a computer
stacked on it yeah that's where I worked
all day do you believe big time that
identity shaped by these associations in
everybody's life 100 talk about that for
a second so it's so aggressive and it's
now getting repeated so I fear trite
words but words become trite because
they're so true that people repeat them
until they lose their meaning so you're
the average of The Five People You spend
the most time with that's just true and
but now it's become so common to say and
it's like every Instagram post that I
fear it's going to lose its meaning who
are you spending time with because if
you're spending time with people like
you you're spending time with people
like me I'm I'm raising you up or I'm
just not going to spend time with you so
it's like now if you get in a mix of
people like that who are like man we'd
love for you to raise up to this level
but if you don't it's fine but we're
just not going to spend time with you
all of a sudden that desire to belong to
something powerful that you can see is
going to lead you to your dreams and I
remember saying to my wife over and over
and over they are the surest path to my
success I don't know anything else I
just know if I can hang on to these guys
they're going to make me better
literally the first time I wrote this
whole article it was my first blog
article and it was all about how if I
were hit by a drunk driver I would take
ownership of that I would say that is my
fault and people were pissed and I was
so shocked I literally thought I want to
pull people from The Matrix what's the
one gift that I could give people that
will change their life forever
and I wrote this whole thing and I was
like talking about like oh man you're in
this spot and it ends up being a kill
box and there's cars on either side of
you in a car in front of you and your
horn dies and you can't even start your
car and move you look in the rearview
mirror and this drunk driver's plowing
down they Smash Into You
and it's all your fault
and thank God
because now you remember that you're in
control
but people thought I was victim shaming
people were outraged
that I would say that that was anyone's
fault but the drunk driver
but I don't want to do that
because I choose not to ever be a victim
I cannot choose whether I'm victimized
but I have the ability to say I will
never
be a victim
because there's always something you can
do differently
there is always something you can do
differently
and once you understand that you can
always make a different choice and get a
different reaction and that's the power
in your life that's the power that you
have is no matter what's going on you
can choose to think differently believe
differently see differently
all of those things are a choice read
Man's Search for meaning by Victor
Frankel lost this whole family to the
Holocaust was in I think five different
concentration camps
and he said the thing that people die of
in a concentration camp is the loss of a
why
and Nietzsche said if you have a why you
can survive almost any how
because you can always change how you
think about something
and when you change how you think about
it's what we've been talking about all
day when you change how you think about
it you actually change the event here's
the problem I find most people have they
judge themselves to the lens of a moment
they fail at something
they miss the honor Club
they don't close that deal they thought
they were going to they embarrass
themselves they flub something
and they think that defines who they are
but I'm telling you right now you're not
defined by who you are you're defined by
who you want to become and the price
you're willing to pay to get there
here's the hard truth about getting
great
it takes time and dedication it takes a
willingness to accept that you're not
yet good enough it takes the ability to
stare at the places that you know that
you're weak to really look at those
things and not let it affect your sense
of self-esteem and not let it affect
your sense of self
their skill set to relentlessly look at
the things that they're not doing well
to understand that they have to break
themselves down and get rid of all of
their ego before they can really find
greatness
those are the people that we remember
so if you want to be remembered if you
want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day
and take another swing take another
photo try another task do something that
scares you and do those little things
over and over and over until you win so
the one thing I will say is I was
grandly ambitious I always said I'm
going to be rich I'm going to do this
I'm going to do that always always since
the time I was a little kid but I didn't
have the drive to see it through so I
really really was an empty dreamer when
I was a kid and it was learning to
hate that in myself if I'm completely
honest and to not allow myself to be an
empty dreamer to force myself to get the
skills to actually execute against it to
not be in any way shape or form pacified
by saying I'm gonna do something which
is actually super dangerous most people
just thinking about the fantasy of what
they're going to do gives them some
partial sense of oh I've done it whereas
I stopped letting that be okay for me
which largely came down to embarrassment
I felt around my wife working when I had
no job and that was the time she was my
fiance at the time but that was when I
really started to go okay you've made a
lot of promises to this woman and you're
not on a path to keep any of them Tom am
I going to make it
do I have what it takes
when you look into my future can you see
me making it
and I'm going to cut to the chase for
all of you and you're going to mistake
what I'm about to say for good news
and then I'm going to tell you why it's
actually
the worst thing I could tell you
you all meet minimum requirements
you all meet minimum requirements
so whatever it is you want to do I'm not
going to say that it's going to be easy
for you because you're Ultra smart or
something you probably aren't
but everyone that I've encountered here
literally without exception every single
person that has come up to me and said
something you meet minimum requirements
even you awkward to have a hard time
like making eye contact even you guys
I'm telling you right now you've got
some you're gonna have to deal with
but you meet minimum requirements now
minimum requirements for what
[Music]
for whatever you want
now that sounds great right
oh
Tom said I can make it this is amazing
but all I've actually said
is now
if you don't make it
it's on you
and that's it
there's nobody else to blame
everything
is your fault
everything once you understand the whole
reason to acquire a skill
is that it gives you power
now I'm going to Define power
to me
is the ability to close your eyes
and imagine a world the world the way
you wish it was
and then open your eyes and make that
world come true
that's power
and the thing that stands between you
where you are today and your goals where
you want to get is a gap in skill set it
is a gap in abilities
and once you're willing to look nakedly
at your inadequacies to literally build
your self-esteem your entire sense of
self-worth and value is built around one
thing whenever you face an obstacle
whenever you face a difficulty whenever
you fail you have one thing that you say
to yourself
on a long enough timeline I can learn
this
when you switch your life around to that
whatever your goal is here whatever part
of the honors club or the Leading Edge
you're at or if you want to go beyond
that
whatever that is
wherever you want to go plant that flag
identify the skills that you would need
to get there and then set about every
day getting those skills people get the
do part they understand their actions
should be actions that take them towards
what they want to accomplish but people
often miss the most important part which
is only to believe things that move you
towards your goals
and I see people every day
that tell themselves the story about
themselves that they are worthless
that they're meaningless
that they're pointless
that their friends and family would be
better off if they just died
so we have to find a way to construct a
narrative about ourselves
that empowers us that lifts us up even
though
even though we make mistakes even though
we fall down even though
we're never going to get things right
all the time and even though terrible
things happen to us
or maybe we do terrible things
but in that the erosion of the self
that's the danger the erosion of the
self that is the danger
and when I talk to people about the 80
20 principle 80 of the time you should
be focused on the things that you love
the beautiful things that you want to
bring to this world the beautiful things
that are already in the world
and 20 of the time you should be kicking
yourself in your ass and saying you can
do better
it's such a powerful idea
but the problem is when people get to
the 20 they forget that it's only
supposed to be 20 of the time and that
it's meant to be these acute moments
where you're pushing yourself to be more
to do more it isn't so you can tear
yourself down that's why you have to do
and believe that which moves you towards
your goals and if thinking that you're a
worthless piece of moves you to your
goals somehow then fine do it but I
can't literally fathom a universe in
which that would be a logical way to
move forward
so I'm going to give you the magic words
that you need right now to never fall
prey to that
believing I'm worthless does not serve
me and I don't do things that don't
serve me
repeat that in your head every time you
begin to disparage yourself here's the
harsh reality
you're just not good enough yet as Brian
Tracy said your true success in life
begins only when you make the commitment
to become excellent at what you do
this is the gap that I see in most
people's lives
they've not yet made the commitment to
become extraordinary and the reason that
they haven't made that commitment yet is
they don't believe that they can they're
afraid of what it might take to get
there they just don't want it enough
that's the reality most people don't
want it enough to face all of that they
don't want to face their inadequacies
they don't want to accept that they're
going to have to go through that process
that gut-wrenching back-breaking process
of becoming great and every day lulls
them into this sense that there's always
time to do it tomorrow but the reality
is there is only now there is only today
and if you really want to do something
with your life that leaves your own jaw
on the floor that leaves you in awe of
what you've done
you're going to have to admit you're not
yet good enough
you've got to put in that work that
you've got to develop a set of skills
that simply can't be denied but if you
do that on the other side of getting
that good at falling in love with
something and working so hard that you
can feel yourself changing as a human
being on the other side of that
Something unimaginably Beautiful
and as Les Brown said if you set goals
and go after them with all the
determination you can muster your gifts
will take you places
that will Amaze you
that's what I want in my life and I hope
that's what you want in yours is to be
amazed to be amazed at how extraordinary
this life really is this opportunity to
make of yourself anything you want to be
really think about that for a second you
can become anything you want to become
you could become an astronaut a
world-class athlete a musician the best
parent that this world has ever seen
anything you want is yours for the
taking
but it takes effort it takes a
willingness to stare nakedly at your
inadequacies it takes a willingness to
really gut check yourself about where
you are today and it doesn't mean that
you can't go and be something better
tomorrow and falling in love with that
process that knowing that being a human
and really getting the most out of your
potential is that to know that tomorrow
I can be better than I am today and that
doesn't make you a bad person today it's
okay to know that you can be better
tomorrow and still love yourself today
it's also okay to love yourself today
and demand that you get better tomorrow
and once you can do that there is
literally nowhere you can't go so I
would get kicked in the face and I would
do something really dumb I'd be called
an idiot told how stupid I was and then
I'd just be like all right I need to
re-center and that just became my
obsession I need to be able to
emotionally get back to complete neutral
so fast that you don't even see a
register on my face how'd you do it how
do you do that literally practice so I
could get I could be in a situation
where I'm being berated or I
legitimately mess up and it costs money
and it's like whoa that's on me and it
is nobody's bad of my own and I realize
that what most people do their strategy
is to deflect it it's your fault it's
not my fault yes so I started thinking
of this as a metaphor people are
throwing gold at me they're throwing it
really hard and I can put a shield up
and deflect it but then I lose that
piece of gold if I drop my shield and
just take the pain let it hit me in the
head then I bend down and go this thing
which was me being stupid there's a
lesson here and now I have this piece of
gold but the whole thing is I have to be
defenseless so I have to own it I have
to take take it I can't fight if someone
is like this to this day if our team is
like hey there's something we need to
point out to you I'll do this
square up to it I want them to know like
hey I want to hear it I want to know
like I want to be literally physically
open I'm not going to close down I'm
going to do everything I can to square
off to open myself so that they know I'm
receptive to the criticism right because
that's the Nugget of gold what I know is
it's Gonna Hurt it's gonna sting but if
I can emotionally re-center so fast you
don't even see that I went through
something now I can just process how do
I take this information you've given me
and get better I went through the pain
of living the cliche of money Camp by
happiness early so that was the very
thing that gave birth to my true
financial success so walk me through
that though so most people will never
experience what it's like to come into
crazy wealth yeah it is it is a really
funny moment and funny is the right word
um it's it's fun but it's also funny in
that when I was growing up part of the
reason I wanted to get rich was I looked
at those people with admiration and I
did not look at myself with admiration
so I thought oh well if I can get
wealthy then I will look at myself with
admiration to be amazing and then when I
got the money by then I had changed
myself fundamentally as a person and I
had earned so much self-respect and so
much self-worth that by the time I got
the money I didn't I wasn't looking for
anything from the money other than it is
the great facilitator it will let you do
extraordinary things but it won't make
you an extraordinary person it won't
make you feel any differently about
yourself and because the money came
literally like that because we had paper
wealth so I was a worth hundreds of
millions of dollars on paper but I just
cannot stress enough that's meaningless
in your real life I was driving you know
at one point a beat up Ford Focus my
wife and I had to share it had a leaky
exhaust and yet I'm worth at that point
I was worth tens of millions of dollars
but there were employees that were
living far better lives than I was from
a financial standpoint so that's paper
money now bank account money came in an
instant and so it was about I don't know
six years into our journey and we
decided to take a small investment to
diversify so it was a pure founder
liquidity moment and because the
valuation of the company was over a
billion dollars you can imagine even at
a small percentage just the raw number
of dollars is insanity so all of a
sudden I was fantastically wealthy but I
was like
it is so in fact this this was how that
day went so
everyone I said earlier you beliefs
values identity habits routines right
these are the things that make people up
and I just have a value system that says
it's not about the money it's about
building something you believe in it's
about serving other people it's about
work ethic it's about showing up and
working and I value myself for that so
on the day that the money hit it hit it
like I don't know 8 A.M in the morning
or something
and my wife were both in the gym and
she's like what are we gonna do today
and I was like what do you mean I'm
going to work and she like couldn't wrap
her head around though she's like whoa
we're gonna go to the Lamborghini dealer
yeah she's like come on we've got to
like go do something we've got to
celebrate and I'm like there's no
Universe in which I don't show up for
work today none under no circumstances
so if you were to ask my employees when
did the money hit they'll be like I have
no idea they knew that it did hit but
they didn't know what day because I
acted completely the same and the thing
that I want people to understand is I
feel the same so all of the like things
that I believe about myself to be good I
still believe to be good I earned them I
earned them by doing the hard thing time
and time and time and time again I know
how much I'm willing to serve people and
my family and myself and all I just know
I've done it for years and years and
years so when it came to do I buy an
island and retire or do I double down it
came down to what will make me love my
life the most and the reality is the
thing that would make me love my life
the most because it would still be fun
to just go and be with my wife but the
thing that will make me love my life the
most is to do the things that are
fulfilling and I think fulfillment has a
very specific Universal formula and that
formula is work your ass off to get very
good at something that you care deeply
about that allows you to serve not only
yourself but other people that's it and
for me it was I grew up in a morbidly
obese family my uncle essentially ate
himself to death when I was 12 years old
and it was scary and sad my mom is
morbidly obese has been my entire life
my sister's morbidly obese has been
almost her entire life my dad at one
point was morbidly obese and then lost
weight but it was like that's just where
my family lives yeah and so I was like
they're going to die far sooner than
they need to and there's this great
Mother Teresa quote nobody will ask for
the many but people will act for the one
and so I just needed to wake up every
day and think about my mom and my sister
and that was it and I thought I can show
up every day and fight for them it's not
about the money anymore here's
this may be the biggest problem we face
as a society
people don't remember that skills have
utility they let you do something
you don't learn to build a house to
impress your parents you learn to build
a house so people can live in the house
you build and once people understand
that like holy you're building this
house so somebody can live in it build a
home in it have a family be sheltered
from storms like it's a real thing man
and so all of that effort and energy
went into I have the chills right now is
so you can create that moment for
yourself for other people it is it is
something so much more than going to
architecture school which maybe you went
to because your parents wanted that and
they they were Architects and so you do
that thing for that and you forget that
the whole reason you became an architect
was to build houses and so once people
realize oh I'm putting all of this time
and energy to build these things because
they let me do something what do I want
to do what do I want to give what do I
want to create when you look at skills
from that perspective it is like
it is being a superhero it is being a
superhero you're going to collect these
abilities these abilities actually let
you do something the fact that Superman
can fly allows him to save people allows
him to do things other people can't do
we all have this opportunity to become
capable of the extraordinary to be able
to do things other people can't do and
that feels so good if you want another
amazing Tom bill you video check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there